foreign
way before Jordan became a god Jordan
and I
we used to regularly show up at
conferences we shared students a lot we
we had some public debates I mean in the
proper good sense
and so Jordan shares with me this this
idea of relevance realization as a as a
core problem to be explained and
understood
and that that the relevance realization
gives us that sense of religio that
sense of connectedness because we're
it's how we're coupled
non-propositionally to the world the
unit we've already talked about this
Jordan and I share that a lot and he's
very very interested and often
supportive of the work I do on relevance
realization intelligence consciousness
meaning and the cultivation of wisdom
and so that's where we have some very
significant agreements
he places more emphasis on the narrative
on narrative than I do I think
non-narrative I think narrative is very
important I want to make that very clear
I don't I don't think we become
temporally extended moral agents without
narrative but I think their narrative
depends on pre-narrative dialogical
capacities and we can move post
narrative because this is what many
people in wisdom Traditions mystical
Traditions report they move post
narrative and you see techniques for
getting people to go post narrative like
think about the Zen Cohen it's designed
to get you into a narrative and then
break narrative apart or Jesus of
nazareth's Parables that's they sound
like stories and there's a narrative and
you read the prodigal son and then who
am I supposed to identify with who's
right like is it this is it the father
is it the prodigal son is it the L and
you realize if you settle on any one of
those you haven't got it and it blows
The Narrative apart you know and Jesus
sorry this it sounds pretentious I mean
it respectfully Jesus is a master of
saying these things that sort of blow
people apart
right Blow The Narrative apart so I
think he and we have done this publicly
he and I had a discussion with Jonathan
pajo and you know and I was challenging
Jonathan and
Jordan about the emphasis on the
narrative and that of course comes from
Jordan from his
his jungian background and from Jonathan
from his Eastern Orthodox although
Jonathan to give him
do credit came around later and he
released a video where he said John's
right the nomological is not reducible
to the narrative there's ways in which
we connect to reality that are
non-narrative and are important I
thought that was really good of him so
that would be one area where Jordan and
I disagree do you have to get the
narrative before you can go post
narrative I think so I think so and and
this is where I think the difference is
I think that narrative is indispensable
but I do not think that means it's
metaphysically necessary let me give you
an analogy my only language that I'm
fluent in is English English is
indispensable to be being a cognitive
agent and communicating but I wouldn't
claim it is metaphysically necessary
that every cognitive agent speak in
English and only in English or or has to
know English you know that's ridiculous
see so you have to make a distinction
between indispensability and I think
narrative is developmentally
indispensable but I don't think it's
metaphysically necessary to our to the
full development of our cognition okay
so you have that disagreement you have
different weighting of narrative and
the alter not the alternative but the
term that you mentioned your your
colleague used the normal logical having
to deal with a lot of structures the
Lilac structures are reality there we go
laws and theories are powerful and
important in a way that's not reducible
to narratives right that's one area and
then another area is I put a lot more
emphasis on practices and theorizing and
helping to engineer practices and
Ecology of practices than Jordan does
that's another major difference why do
you think that is what would his
response to that be would you imagine
part of it I think In fairness to him is
background and part of it has to do I
think with
Jordan is a very complex person I
respect Jordan I consider him a
colleague and I consider him a friend
and what I want to say very clearly and
I and I do this to his face by the way
and because I do it respectfully and
dialogically Jordan is fine with this we
disagree about things for example I
think post-modernism and Foucault
there's a lot to be learned there I have
criticisms of them but there are
important arguments that need to be
engaged with I have argued this with
Jordan to his face he disagrees he
thinks that post-modernism is largely
crypto Marxism
etc etc and he rejects it sort of to
core I'm not I'm not denying that
that post-modernism has been taken by
people in this way but I would also say
that many people invoke derida and
Foucault and they've not actually read
darada and Foucault Darren I was very
interested in
neoplatonism and Foucault was very
interested toward in Hado and stoicism
towards the end of his career and
there's reasons for that I think you
have to have a much more nuanced
understanding of post-modernism now I've
made that argument to Jordan any and we
disagree about it but because I respect
him and we enter into genuine dialogue
that's fine right now the problem is
Jordan also has this other side where
and he doesn't do this with me
where he gets he's very confrontational
and he admits this and he gets very
polemical
and it's usually in the political domain
and that's that's an area when he and I
don't agree very much
but
to his credit right you know
Jordan respects that he and I can have
significant different political
commitments and nevertheless get into
deep and important discussions of
philosophical and scientific Merit
I have to say that because I'm really
tired of people saying that because I
talked to Jordan and because I maintain
the relationship that pre-existed his
godhood that I am somehow
you know
advising or advocating for all of
everything he says that's ridiculous I
directly criticize him about a lot of
things it's just I think it should be
done in the way that we do it and we've
always done it and so
that's a hard thing my relationship to
him is a challenge for me I've
considered both options I've considered
sort of just sort of throwing in and I'm
part of the petersonian camp and it's
like no I can't do that I can't do that
in all honesty I disagree with Jordan
about politics as the main area I
disagree for philosophical reasons with
Jordan about politics being the main
area in which we can solve the meaning
crisis politics is at the propositional
level and is at the adversarial level we
need the we need the non-propositional
that's the main place where the meaning
crisis is going to be addressed I would
argue I disagree with him about that
I've disagreed with him about particular
philosophical stances like his stance on
post-modernism
Etc
and so completely identifying him would
be inauthentic completely rejecting him
would be inauthentic we share a lot of
concerns we I admire many of his ideas I
think he's made he's done good work
published work he continues to make good
arguments he's an insightful person and
I have an ongoing history with him and
he he talks to people that I talk to
like so I'm in this I'm damned if I do
damned if I don't so I I sort of just
say well okay what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to show up and interact
with him as philosophically and
scientifically honestly as I can